two budding entrepreneurs will face off
to win
major prizes that will help boost their
businesses
even further so are you ready to meet
some of the businesses
check this out hey everyone i'm jasmine
hey i'm justin we are husband and wife
team and also the co-founders of our
company morning joyco i am one of the
founders of hanks office i'm the founder
and creative director of localiobi
i am the co-founder and ceo of cc's
closet
nyc i'm the founder of bestsell color
glass i own the craft studio
i am the owner and operator of
farmerslaughter fibers i'm the owner and
operator of
the norte studio to drew thank you so
much for finding us and featuring us on
your website it means
so so much to us hundreds of followers
since then tons of online orders
that people obviously trust drew's
opinion she's got great taste this
holiday season
was truly the busiest one we've had
in the last five years due to the fact
that we were featured in the drew
barrymore show
thank you seriously so much for all that
you're doing to support small businesses
we appreciate you taking the time to do
this for us
and for everyone else that you've
supported as well
hey i'm kristen and i own keller works
naturals
i started my business nine years ago
because my son elliot has severe
eczema and i couldn't find soap on the
market to meet his needs
since then we've done a lot of really
cool things
one of the most exciting has been being
featured on drew barrymore social media
soon after the order started pouring in
we could hardly manage
we're so super grateful for the
opportunity that she's given us
we are the owners of colonel's nashville
popcorn we specialize in freshly popped
gourmet popcorn
including our national hot popcorn we
are a family owned business and when you
come to colonels
you are part of our family too thank you
so much to barrymore show for featuring
us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so cool and i have to thank our digital
team and the producers and everyone who
wrote in on my personal social media
when i made this call to action so that
we could highlight these small
businesses
so every single one of them is amazing
and we've got many to continue to shine
a light on
but for now we've chosen two for our
first small
business challenge so please welcome
kristin keller the founder of keller
works in mobile alabama
and sisters erica amber and jennifer
the founders of colonel's nashville
popcorn in nashville tennessee
oh i'm just so happy to be doing this
with you guys
and i know this is so personal for you
so thank you for letting us into our
world and today you're gonna have to
pitch
um your businesses and i'd like to
welcome
my fellow judge um who is a dear friend
in 2002
she started her own business out of her
bedroom with just 500
and today her company is valued at over
a billion that's a billion with a
b dollar
this is a woman i would ask business
advice from
any day of the year please welcome the
incredible kendra scott
i'm so happy to meet you amazing female
founders what a treat for me today to be
yeah
nice to meet you too
well ladies would you like to know uh
what you're playing for
yes okay let's take a look the winner of
today's small business challenge will
win
big they will receive a marketing
package which includes a feature on the
home page of our show's website
a one-on-one meeting with the one and
only kendra scott whose award-winning
company is worth a billion
dollars that's billion with the b in
addition
the winning business will also receive a
consultation with top pr
executive and branding expert alison
broad
who has worked with companies such as
l'oreal old navy bed bath beyond and
burger king
and to top it off today's winner will
also receive a 10
000 cash prize
[Applause]
thank you so are you ready for your
small
business challenge first up kristin what
is your pitch
and what is your story hi i'm kristen
i'm the founder of keller works naturals
we're a sensitive skin care company we
make products for people with eczema and
allergies
nine years ago my little boy elliot
developed a rash on his face
and it quickly spread all over his body
we took him to about 14 different
doctors
and found out that it was caused by
eczema
from his allergies so i looked and
looked for products to help maintain his
skin
and i couldn't find anything free of his
allergens
which led me to create my own skin care
line within two weeks
the the rash had completely cleared
everyone around us
noticed and they said what did you use
and where do i get it
that's when i knew i had a business and
there was a need and i could fill it
thank you so much drew for the
opportunity to be on the show
thank you kristen and
kendra do you have a question for
kristen
yes so what does your competitive
landscape look like
who are you competing against and what
makes your product stand out from theirs
my competitors that i usually focus on
are companies like
cerave but the leg up that i have on
that
is the fact that we're all natural and
we use no chemicals whatsoever in our
product
i know you think that the what separates
you is some of just what's in the
product what separates you
is you your story your experience
your relatability to other mothers and
parents
you have that over any one of your
competitors that are in drug stores
across america
so celebrate that absolutely that's
excellent advice
thank you so much erica amber
jennifer it's your turn what is your
pitch and what is your story
okay so we are the sisters of colonel's
national popcorn
our story starts a long time ago when we
were kids
our parents always got us the popcorn
tins for christmas you know the caramel
cheddar and butter
and we just gobble it up every every
holiday
season and so it just became a family
tradition so
we fast forward some years and um it was
christmas break of 2007 and we were just
sitting around casually talking and
jennifer has the idea
what if we have a open a popcorn store
in nashville because there wasn't one
anymore
and when she said that i just
immediately envisioned like what it
could
grow into what it could be so in 2008
we started doing events and festivals
and we started
gaining a following so we decided to
open a store for front in 2013
and now colonel's has 14 delicious
flavors yes kendra what are your
thoughts and what are your questions
first of all i see when i was kind of
reading about you guys you have big
dreams for this business
you want it to go bigger right you want
to be able to build your online
how are you going to do that and compete
you think against
other popcorn businesses out there
uh what makes us set a part is
the experience that you have when you
come to kernels
we treat you like family yeah definitely
i'm just so i love that because in our
stores at kendra scott we have what's
called the kendra scott sister rule
is treating your customer like your
sister and then your customer service is
really easy
right and so you guys have that
create experience i love all of those
things so
great job there thank you
kendra yes i think
um that we both agree um that these
businesses
are deserving and um
i think kendra and i feel um that the
winners should be both of you
both businesses
[Applause]
you are each going home with a
one-on-one meeting with kendra scott
um on the home page of our show's
website with a ton
of support and a consultation with top
pr executive and branding expert allison
broad
and then we're going to throw in ten
thousand dollars
kristen erica and amber jennifer thank
you guys
so much and kendra
i just love doing this with you so much
go to our website to learn more about
these small businesses
and our others